oreo broadcaster melanie newman there
she is
she's become the first female
broadcaster in franchise history to call
play-by-play
melanie will handle play-by-play duties
on the 44 station orioles radio network
and becomes the fourth active female
game broadcaster
and major league baseball joining jenny
cavner of the rockies
susan waldman of the yankees and jessica
mendoza of espn with go melanie
john means his second start of the year
look for john means to be back on point
like he was last year was an all-star
caliber season
all-star caliber first half for john
means he's healthy
i look for this start to be much better
two down just underway
here's the veteran corey dickerson
sponsored to alberto
and means retires the marlins in the
first
on the mound pablo lopez was supposed to
start last monday in the home opener
here at marlins park instead
he gets the ball on the road against the
same baltimore orioles
lopez home with a 2-2 pitch nicely done
gets the strikeout and there's one away
in the first
two down and renato nunez the third
baseman will be the batter
here comes the pitch swing and a miss
and uh quick easy two strikeout first
inning for pablo lopez chris davis at
the plate right now
davis won for 13 on the year dawson
hayes leads off
first after the infield single and a
swing and a miss
another strikeout for pablo that's three
top of the third scoreless game and a
little play by blank here's melanie
monte harrison with his debut against
john means
the 2-2 home harrison swing enemies and
strikeout number two
for john means of the evening two away
on top of the third
quickly nothing into dj stewart who is
over 12
to begin the year out in left field
tonight
cervelli wanted it upstairs and another
strikeout for pablo lopez making four
throughout the answer alberto comes up
for the oriole
struck out alberto in the first and
again
in the third he's got five in a
scoreless game
fourth inning begins here john means
comes home to john bertie
2-2 to birdie and he got him swinging
strikeout number three for john means
one two again and dickerson finally was
chased out by
john means the change-up and he offers
three up three down
four here's francisco cervelli
the marlins going with cervelli and ryan
lavarnway as their two catchers this
is lined in the left and it's over the
wall
a line drive home run for francisco
cervelli
the zumba classes are working i'll tell
you what cervelli had the best swing
first time through the lineup against
means laid off a 2-1 change-up earned
himself a 3-1
fastball and did not miss it
now pedro severino will come to the
plate
pablo's 3-2 pitch and again goes to the
change-up
that's his sixth strikeout runner at
second base two down
d.j stewart the batter if it is swung on
and missed
terrific location puts stewart away
john brewery marlins a chance for
another
home run from cervelli in the fifth
and birdie comes through a base hit into
center field vr
rounding third no throw from austin
hayes and john
ferdi doubles the marlins lead now two
nothing
anderson at first base dickerson at
second base birdie over at third base
with pool away and a two to nothing
marlins lead
sixth batter of the inning logan forsyth
grounded two
third bobbled at third and the inning
will continue
right at nunez that'll be his first
error of the year and more importantly
for the marlins give them a
three-nothing lead
now jesus aguilar go for three in the
ball game of fly out to right
round out and the lineup our way to
drive
oh my goodness whoa
long gone for jesus aguilar his third of
the year
another insurance run for the marlins
keeps swinging that magic guy
my goodness yeah this is a center cut
fastball that aguilar just unloads on
four nothing let's go here in the bottom
of the eighth
uh looking at lake at a pinch hit here
here 02.
and box burger paints that one two way
here in the eighth
season high 11th strikeout tonight for
the marlins
again a few two two out pitch bounces
off the middle shortstop has his vr
sidearms to first and boxberger with
scoreless eighth inning
the marlins are in control tonight at
camden yard
here's dwight smith jr and there are two
way
ground ball second base john bertie
there it's
a marlins win after eight days off
they get a phenomenal start from pablo
lopez
and uh a deep breath with all that fresh
air for the marlins a deep breath after
a four-nothing shutout win